on the headline Punjabi he said Punjabi
separatist
assassinated I said oh
no they got trud though they got they
got it they got Justus thinder how the
hell how the hell did they assassinate
just
sinder did they force him to kiss his
wife on camera how
did then I look up the details of the
story the dude was assass
India sent some [__] here to
assassinate I'm like why is nobody
talking about this [__] story then I
looked up the guy who's assassinated
[Music]
name his first name is
Hardeep his last name is spelled ni
JJ
[Applause]
ER that's too close that's too [__]
close I'm I'm sorry white people we
can't share this story we got to sit
this one out I saw punjabis in the
streets like say his name we're like we
would love to but we can't we just can
you even give us that pass can you give
us an nwor
pass all I'm saying Toronto is
unbelievable an Indian was killed on
Canadian
soil and it wasn't in a residential
school man can you
believe by the way the name of this
theater is the most Jewish name I've
ever
heard Meer Horowitz
theater is this next to the bagel drel
Arena
what bro that turban is Big
Dog hold on I got to see I've never seen
it hey put the spot on
bro you got to be considered for the
people behind you for the show dude you
wore your tallest
turban damn bro do they got different
heights is today like a really religious
day that you got
the are you like the king
Punjab so that's a high one is that not
a high one cuz you never cut your hair
huh so you got to wrap all that [__] in
there dog you know what you could do you
could cut it and no one would [__]
know
why do some of them have a knot but
yours
doesn't like some of them have a
knot yeah the knot is up there but yours
looks like you could put like apples and
pears and [__] on the
[Applause]
top sorry what there's layers to it so
wait are you like a better version of
Indian wait you earn that you earn the
bowl and then how do you earn that one
what do you you got to do you turned
12 holy [__] dude it's like the opposite
of Jews like you get a little bit more
on your
[Applause]
head I didn't know y'all had a bar
mitzvah what's it called when you turn
12 dude mitah thank you sweetheart I'm
talking to the
guy are you the representative for Meer
horrorwitz here is
[Music]
it what is it bro what is it
called the
star thank you
dog I can't imagine how big your [__] is
cuz you know
[Applause]
it
this [__] walking around like
the pope of India
dog yo Punjabi be honest when Trudeau uh
did the Punjabi face
and what was more offensive that he put
on the turban or he made y'all dark skin
which was more
[Applause]
offensive yeah there's a bunch of bavi
in the group chat like yo how the [__]
you going to make us s Lankan bro this
is crazy y we from the north of India
we're fair skinned we light-skinned
Indians over here get it right
trudo want this guy Trudeau shut the
[__] up this guy does anybody I I me
honest does anybody like
him nobody likes it right I know that's
funny scared of some truckers you saw
that [__] well they have Co I can't come
out
it [__] [__] dude what a [__]
[__] what a
[__] his dad would be so embarrassed
dude cuz Fidel Castro was all about
protest
and
yo you know what I got to say it's it's
been really nice to watch uh Toronto get
its
confidence cuz when I started coming
here you guys were like polite sweets
you know Canadians apologetic about
everything but just like so
accommodating and now you're just
[__] Jamaican and and that's great
and that's great you just said [__] it
we watch one top boy and we're all
Jamaican it doesn't matter who it is
little white kid's like fam fam come on
fam fam the gam at Timmy's come on
fam reach Timmy's the gam is wet and
horny fam come on fam reach Tim right
now there's a bunch of Wast man trying
to take down these guyss at their Tim
bunch of fish
[Applause]
boys
calm down you're from Hamilton okay you
don't talk like that you grew up playing
hockey on a pond shut the [__]
up there's no way we could
go and broken what we
had I wish come
[Music]
around godamn handsome Indian look at
you are you Indian or Pakistani Indian
yeah relax there's
[__] two billion of you you don't
have to get
that Hindu Muslim sick what are
you no [__]
[__] I'm saying what's the
background why y'all take so long for
this
[__] Bombay from Bombay and what you're
just naming more [__] that you know
doesn't what's their religious
background they're not religious either
what about their
parents you don't know
them you know you you know I know you're
lying right you
know you know I know you're lying right
now none of us ever met a non-religious
Indian parent in our
life none of us ever met a Indian parent
Indian parent
non-religious uh-uh that's what he got
to say cuz his girl ain't Indian that's
[Applause]
what they weren't feeling that [__] were
they what's your back you're Asian right
Miss what type of
Asian you're Taiwanese that's a good one
n that's a good one that's like China
2.0 right cuz the
Taiwanese right I'm getting that right
Taiwanese were like [__] it we
out and then they were like Japan's too
far let's just stop right here this
island n this Island's good we're not
going all the
way you're like you're like those
Indians that made it to like
Trinidad you know the Indians like we're
going to America and then the first
Islander like [__] it pull over pull
over this is far
enough I'm
[Music]
ready they were so close
bro now they out there in the Caribbean
Thunder
clapping they went
[Applause]
from what about you other Indian I don't
even know if you're Indian I assume
you're Indian all right what type of
Indian I am Punjabi Punjabi are you sick
you're sick that's what's up man [__]
with six
man those are the dudes that wear the
turban and [__] and they got that
bracelet that little silver
bracelet that's a badass
bracelet no for real cuz back in the day
that used to be a sheath that would
protect them from swords cuz the six
were the warrior class of people in
India and then over the years you know
the meaning has changed now it's used to
rest on a steering wheel of a uber
[Applause]
but
son if they got that bracelet locked on
that steering wheel
though they never crashing dude never
crashing you let Vishnu Take the Wheel
[Applause]
dog now that's Hindu ain't it that's
Hindu did I get that right at least I
got
that crazy man you got that one perfect
were your parents okay with you dating a
black
guy they were surprisingly okay with it
man your sister must be a
doctor you got a younger
brother and he's doing everything right
I love [__] that's what's up that's
that brown parents [__] Brown parents
don't give a [__] about the daughter
bro daughter is meaningless yo it's just
taking up food that the sun could be
eating b b don't eat all the chicken
your brother needs some chicken bter B B
please B please he's a growing
boy he needs it for his
brain you clearly don't need it because
you're D black
gu I take you all to this country till
you de black eyes if I wanted that I
would have taken you to South India